¿Alguna vez os habéis preguntado como se
puede secuestrar un país?
¿Cómo se pueden someter, pervertir y corromper
las instituciones?
y la más importante de todas, ¿Cómo identificar
el momento en el que una democracia tras ser
secuestrada deja de funcionar?
Amigos, durante años, estas han sido preguntas
que han condicionado la política internacional…
pero sobre todo la política de América Latina.
Durante las últimas décadas han sido numerosos
los caudillos latinoamericanos que han tomado
el control de sus países.
En ocasiones lo hicieron mediante golpes de
estado… pero en otras muchas ocasiones estos
caudillos llegaron al poder por vías democráticas.
Este es precisamente, el caso del Presidente
de Nicaragua, Daniel Ortega.
Amigos, aquí, en VisualPolitik, ya os hemos
hablado de este personaje político, de cómo
llegó al poder, cómo se comportó y de cómo
ha sido el responsable de las enormes protestas
que vive Nicaragua en 2018.
Unas protestas que han sido respondidas con
mano dura y están dejando un saldo atroz:
más de 200 personas han perdido la vida,
los detenidos se cuentan por cientos y los
heridos por miles.
Pues bien, en este vídeo, nos vamos a fijar
en otra faceta de los acontecimientos.
Esta es la historia de cómo un gobierno consiguió
hacerse con el control total del Estado y
poner a las instituciones a trabajar no para
el país, sino para él mismo.
Esta es la historia de como una especie de
mafia política se hizo con las riendas de
Nicaragua.
Atentos.
Año 2006, Daniel Ortega gana las elecciones
presidenciales de Nicaragua.
Tras 16 años en la oposición, el líder
sandinista regresaba a la presidencia del
país.
Los precedentes no eran precisamente buenos:
su primera etapa como presidente entre 1985
y 1990 fue...
terrible.
Ortega dejó un país económica y socialmente
destrozado.
(Un país que de facto estuvo en guerra, que
terminó con una deuda externa 6 veces más
grande que su PIB y una hiperinflación que
tan sólo en 1987 alcanzó la astronómica
cifra del 33.547%)
Para que os hagáis una idea de la magnitud
del desastre, en 1990 la renta per cápita
de Nicaragua era un 55% más que pequeña
que la que el país había registrado en 1978.
[En otras palabras, comparándose con Daniel
Ortega hasta los Kirchner sacarían buena
nota]
Amigos, el modelo económico de Ortega fue
un rotundo fracaso…
las expropiaciones, la gigantesca deuda exterior,
la imparable impresión de dinero y su obsesión
por el control total de la economía…
condujeron a Nicaragua a una situación insostenible.
[Como para no, ¡menuda receta!]
(Y si a todo esto le sumamos el conflicto
con las Contras, financiadas por Estados Unidos,
el desastre para el país fue ya total.)
[Por cierto, apunte: las Contras fueron grupos
paramilitares financiados por Washington mediante,
ojo, la venta de armas a Irán cuando este
país se encontraba en plena guerra con Irak,
un país que supuestamente era cercano a Washington.
En definitiva, un despropósito.]
El caso es que durante la siguiente década
el país solo tuvo una misión: recuperarse
de este desastre.
Para ello, los siguiente gobiernos, empezando
por el de Violeta Chamorro [Por cierto, la
primera presidenta en América Latina elegida
mediante las urnas] apostaron por dar un giro
de 180 grados al planteamiento político y
económico del país.
Es decir, pasar de una economía centralizada,
organizada y dirigida por el estado a una
economía de mercado.
(Así es como nacieron las zonas francas de
Nicaragua y las políticas de atracción de
inversión extranjera, lo que unido a la cooperación
internacional y sobre todo a las crecientes
remesas procedentes del extranjero, permitieron
que Nicaragua comenzara a ponerse de nuevo
en marcha.)
Sin embargo, esperad un momento….
porque lo que no consiguieron estos nuevos
gobiernos fue terminar con la corrupción…
Así, escandalo tras escandalo, la sensación
de frustración, decepción y engaño que
sintieron los nicaragüenses [junto a una
oposición que estaba dispuesto a casi todo
con tal de regresar al poder] alimentaron
la victoria de Ortega en 2006.
Y aquí, amigos, a partir de este momento
comienza una nueva historia…
entre cosas porque Ortega tenía claro que
no iba a desaprovechar su regreso al poder.
Esta era su ocasión, su oportunidad para
dominar la política, las finanzas y la sociedad
nicaragüense.
Pero para lograrlo, y sobre todo, para impedir
que un proceso electoral le volviera a desalojar
de la presidencia, necesitaba hacerse con
el poder político, con el monopolio de la
fuerza y, también, con el poder económico.
Esta es la estrategia que puso en marcha y
los pasos que dio para alcanzar su propósito.
Atentos.
(EL PODER POLÍTICO)
Evidentemente la primera meta en toda esta
estrategia pasa por lograr la hegemonía política
y el control social…
por cualquier medio.
Ortega, lo tuvo muy claro desde el principio
y puso en marcha una doble táctica:
por un lado “invadir” las instituciones
y centralizar el poder, por otro limitar y
amedrentar a la oposición….
algo que para lo que el miedo suele ser un
ingrediente muy, pero que muy eficaz.
De esta forma, al poco de llegar al poder
Ortega puso en marcha una fuerza paramilitar
compuesta por pandilleros.
Hablamos de los grupos de choque, más conocidos
en Nicaragua como las Turbas.
(“Son de temer, y la población los llama
turbas.
Suelen vestir camisetas con leyendas que hablan
de amor y paz, usan cascos para ocultar sus
rostros y se movilizan en motos.
En su mayoría son jóvenes, jóvenes violentos”.
- Matilde Córdoba, periodista en Managua)
¿Su objetivo?
Amedrentar a la oposición política, atemorizar
a quienes discrepan del gobierno y tratar
de reventar mediante la violencia las manifestaciones
o concentraciones de la oposición.
Evidentemente no es una fuerza oficial…
pero cuentan con la protección del gobierno,
en un momento veremos cómo.
(“Podemos decir que en Nicaragua se ha constituido
una fuerza paramilitar que está compuesta
por pandilleros.
A veces nos subimos a un bus y está un paramilitar
observándonos".
- Haydeé Castillo, activista nicaragüense.)
Pero, por supuesto, aquí no termina todo.
El siguiente paso para lograr un poder político
total es hacerte, precisamente, con el control
de las instituciones del estado.
Ahora bien, ¿Cómo pensáis que lo hizo?
Pues… lo primero de todo fue poner fin a
la descentralización política, en este caso
a la autonomía municipal.
De esta forma, en Nicaragua los secuaces políticos
de Ortega han llegado a destituir alcaldes
a su complacencia.
[Algo así como…
oye si tienes un rival político echale de
la carrera, es una forma no solo de eliminar
adversarios, también de ganar fieles que
no quieren correr riesgos]
(Lo segundo, crear y dar legitimidad a sus
propias organizaciones políticas, en este
caso los “Consejos del Poder Ciudadano”.
Unos órganos, supuestamente de participación
comunitaria, pero que en la práctica tienen
el objetivo de crear una estructura política
paralela reconocida y controlada por el gobierno.)
Y lo tercero, nombrar y lograr la permanencia
indefinida de sus allegados de partido en
todos los puestos claves del estado: el Poder
Electoral, el Poder Judicial y la Contraloría
General.
[ Y si un funcionario protesta…
pues para eso están las turbas, ¿no?].
¿Queréis dos pruebas de lo que consiguió
Ortega con toda esta estrategia?
Fijaos.
(La Constitución de Nicaragua prohibía la
reelección consecutiva de un presidente.
De esta forma Ortega hubiera concluido su
mandato en 2011.
Sin embargo, tal y como hizo Hernández en
Honduras, Ortega consiguió que la Sala Constitucional
del Tribunal Supremo, compuesta mayormente
por magistrados sandinistas declarara inaplicable,
el artículo 147, que es el que impedía la
reelección consecutiva del presidente.
A cambio, eso sí, los magistrados lograron
su permanencia vitalicia, de por vida, en
el cargo.)
Por otro lado, en las elecciones de 2011…
las sospechas de fraude fueron tan intensas
que tanto la Unión Europea como la Organización
de Estados Americanos concluyeron que no tenían
certeza de los resultados.
¿Sabeis quien controlaba el Poder Electoral?
Exacto, Ortega se había asegurado de que
sus adeptos pudieran hacer y deshacer a su
antojo.
En las siguientes elecciones, las de 2016…
ya ni se cortaron y el oficialismo se hizo
con el control total del proceso.
Pero…
un momento…
puede que estéis pensando,
Pero...
Enrique, ¿no hubo acaso un gran escándalo?
Bueno, digamos que el presidente se había
encargado de que prácticamente todos los
grandes medios de comunicación del país
están controlados por su famila o por socios
suyos.
(“La Familia Ortega monopoliza los medios
de comunicación en Nicaragua” Diario las
Américas)
Turbas, ocupación de las instituciones y
medios de comunicación, está es la parte
política, pero aún hay más.
(EL MONOPOLIO DE LA FUERZA)
Por mucho que tenga el poder político si
un caudillo no controla la fuerza asume un
riesgo enorme.
Nuestro protagonista lo tenía clarísimo,
así que el segundo pilar en esta estrategia
fue tomar las riendas de la policía y del
ejército.
(Para ello, aprovechando su mayoría en la
Asamblea Nacional, Ortega sacó adelante nada
más llegar al poder una reforma que concentró
en sus manos nuevas facultades como jefe supremo
de la Policía Nacional y del Ejército de
la República.)
Luego, aprovechándose de estas nuevas posibilidades,
puso a familiares y leales directamente al
mando de estas instituciones.
Por ejemplo, la policía está dirigida de
facto por su propio Consuegro, Francisco Díaz…
de tal manera que ante las turbas, la policia
mira para otro lado… y ante las manifestaciones
de la oposición, represión, represión y
represión.
[Y es que cuando la mafia se hace con el poder
no esperes que lo suelte fácilmente]
Pero…
política, fuerza pública…
falta un tercer elemento.
(EL PODER ECONÓMICO)
El tercer pilar en toda esta estrategia fue
lograr el poder económico.
por 3 razones:
primero, para evitar que el capital nicaragüense
apoyará otra alternativa; segundo para lograr
recursos con los que llevar a cabo sus planes
y tercero…
para forrarse, para llenarse el bolsillo.
Durante este tiempo la corrupción ha sido
brutal…
hasta tal punto que hoy la familia Ortega-Murillo
es millonaria, millonaria de verdad.
Fijaos, han tomado el control de medios de
comunicación, han ocupado altos cargos del
estado; ¡se han adjudicado la importación
y distribución de petróleo en Nicaragua!;
se han puesto al frente de las agencias de
promoción de inversión…
con un plan en esta línea
¿Quieres invertir en Nicaragua?
Estupendo te damos facilidades pero a mi das
una comisión.
[Ya sabéis, todo por la patria]
También han llegado a acuerdos con empresarios:
aparentemente, lealtad y sobres a cambio de
privilegios.
(Un caso claro de esta forma de hacer las
cosas fue el acuerdo para construir el Canal
Interoceánico, un proyecto aparentemente
fallido… pero en el que el gobierno llegó
a un acuerdo bajo la mesa con Wanj Jinm, el
empresario chino promotor de la obra.
Al principio el estado se reservaba la mitad
de los benéficios…
al final con un cambio de última hora el
1%.)
[Se ve que el empresario supo regatear en
el último momento…
qué capacidad, ni Messi es capaz de regatear
así]
En fin amigos, el caso es que con el poder
político, con la fuerza y con el poder económico,
Daniel Ortega se hizo dueño y señor de Nicaragua
[Y, bueno, parece que multimillonario también]
Y por si las moscas en las últimas elecciones,
en las de 2016, presentó como Vicepresidenta
a Rosario Murillo, su mujer [Así, todo queda
en casa]
Amigos, todo el proceso que hemos visto es
muy similar a lo acontecido en Venezuela,
es por así decirlo, el manual de todo caudillo.
Y la pregunta que podemos hacernos es, ¿Realmente
podemos pretender pensar que Nicaragua sigue
siendo una democracia?
Déjame tu opinión en los comentarios y como
siempre si te ha resultado interesante el
vídeo dale a like y no olvides suscribirte
a VisualPolitik si aun no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.